ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
first u.s. sponsored inter-parliamentary
conference on the global environment
today together this week we're making
history we begin a task of tremendous
importance with implications for this
generation and every generation to
follow for our children and our
children's children thank you for
joining us here thank you for your
courage leadership vision and your
energy and for the commitment your
presence reflects more than 42 nations
from all parts of the globe are
represented here many different voices
with many different concerns we'll all
be heard during the next three days as
we work together to find one voice with
which we can all speak out to advocate
the policies our global environmental
crisis demands I would like to take just
a moment to recognize the host
delegation from the United States Senate
and ask that members of the host
delegation stand
first of all Senator John Chafee of
Rhode Island the ranking member of the
Senate Environment and Public Works
Committee senator Chafee
Senator John Heinz a member of the
Senate Finance Committee of Pennsylvania
Senator John Kerry of Massachusetts a
member of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee senator Tim Wirth of Colorado
a minute member of the Senate Energy and
Natural Resources Committee two members
of our host delegation senator Rudy
Boschwitz of Minnesota and Senator Max
Baucus of Montana are unable to be with
us this evening what but will be
attending the conference sessions later
on one of our vice chairs from the
United States House of Representatives
is here congressman bill green of New
York of the appropriations committee I
would also like to recognize Walter J
Stewart secretary of the United States
Senate
now I would I take particular pleasure
and great honor in recognizing some of
the delegates who are also the heads of
parliamentary bodies in their own
countries mr. Laurent fabulous president
of the French National Assembly
Nelson Carr narrow president of the
Senate of Brazil
Marco Antonio daughter dawn president of
the Congress of Guatemala Lucian Xavier
Michele Adrian najran in Joc president
of the National Assembly of Madagascar
mutari Musa president of the National
Assembly of Nazaire during the next
three days we will work together in
plenary sessions and in smaller groups
focused intensely on seven different
issues about which we will hear a good
deal more tomorrow we will hear from
scientists researchers policymakers and
even poets we will see the first-ever
whole earth photograph and the very
latest in a special film made from Earth
orbit about our earth our goal will be
to produce specific legislative
strategies for action sensitive to our
various concerns that will mean real
changes and real progress the problem we
are facing is so difficult and
unprecedented that sometimes we must
move beyond mere words to poetry and so
we begin this evening with an original
poem composed especially for this
occasion the first time he has composed
a poem in English the legendary poet of
conscience who is himself a
parliamentarian from the Soviet Union it
is my pleasure to introduce a wonderful
friend and parliamentarian you have
guinea Yevtushenko a delegate to the
soviet congress of people's deputies
such a change of time when American
senator could inspire ration for to
write one for him
I'm sorry for my pronunciation the last
petals dedicated to my brother
senator Al Gore who did a lot of things
for my religion you last purple but
almost not palpable tail petals probably
the last child revolving around the
petals the slow and creaking petals of
probably the last bicycle the rusty
smell of probably the last row remind
reminds in the transparent soul of
probably July ice your lips my beloved
are like last petals on the dried up
Tree of Life
mother earth looks like a widow bleeding
from her own reticle children night we
leave the strange time of the moral
autumn last petals of conscience last
pets last polar bears parrots poets last
political Hickox last profit last
profits last sweet tea tea tea of
probably jealous
very last peaceful pleasure to play
these puzzles I was privileged to have
faces without muscles it the first day
at the funeral of Earth at the day of
come on tours when nobody wants to die
first I feel like a last petal of a
flower not yes
thank you
thank you so much for that original
composition which is so moving to us at
the start of our proceedings before our
keynote speaker we must attend to
several conference formalities by
addressing these matters this evening it
is my hope that we will be able to begin
immediately tomorrow morning with the
formal proceedings of the conference if
there is no objection to proceeding with
these matters for the selection of
officers I turn the podium to President
Laurent fabulous of France president
fabulous is an internationally respected
parliamentarian and president of the
French National Assembly and former
prime minister mr. fabulous we will give
the gavel to you for these conference
formalities mr. fabulous will be
speaking tomorrow morning as well
to give us an international greeting
thank you I will speak English
pidgin English and it will be very very
quick very short I move that the
organizer and chairman of the host
delegation of this conference senator Al
Gore be named the chairman and that we
also name a group of vice-chairman to
assist the chairman in conducting his
duties it's all in any objection to that
difficult decision seeing no objection
the Chairman and vice chairman are so
selected thank you very much thank you
very much we do have two other
procedural matters that it would be
helpful to address briefly this evening
we need to adopt the conference rules
and conference agenda which all of you
received and the package of materials
distributed at registration these are
fairly self-explanatory and if there is
no objection I would propose that we
adopt them is there objection
hearing none the rules and the agenda
are adopted for those who are not
parliamentarians and who have attended
other conferences please understand that
we parliamentarians have to have rules
in order to proceed finally I would ask
that we appoint a coordinating committee
of the conference who shall have the
responsibility of preparing each day's
working documents for consideration by
the conference at large I would suggest
that the Coordinating Committee consist
of the working group chairs and
co-chairs as will be determined by each
working group tomorrow and if there is
no objection we will so designate the
Coordinating Committee thank you for
attention to these matters and now let
me introduce our honored speaker this
evening
our keynote speech tonight comes from an
individual who has helped us dream and
has helped us see what before we could
only imagine Carl Sagan has inspired not
one nation or one people but many
nations and many peoples the children of
those of us here in this room know him
on a first-name basis because he has
taught them so much through the magic of
television all over the world Carl Sagan
is a Pulitzer Prize winning author whose
television series has won Emmy Awards
and Peabody Awards
if I tried to share with you tonight
every award he has earned for his
outstanding contributions to our
understanding of the world he wouldn't
have much time left to speak Carl Sagan
has been a leader in the Mariner Viking
and Voyager expeditions to the planets
for which I might add he received the
NASA medal for exceptional scientific
achievement and many other international
and national awards his scientific
research has enhanced our understanding
of the greenhouse effect on Venus and
here on earth dust storms on Mars the
organic haze on Titan the origin of life
and the search for life elsewhere in the
universe he has most effectively sounded
an alarm that is being heard worldwide
alerting people to the global
environmental crisis before us I am
honored to know Carl Sagan to be able to
call him a friend and tonight to
introduce him to you Carl Sagan
Thank You senator Gore I'm most happy to
be here at this gathering of members of
the human community from all over the
world you know we humans started out in
East Africa some hundreds of thousands
of years ago and spread all over so that
there's hardly a place on the planet
that is not occupied by human beings and
in all that course of time we've been
divided into small communities wandering
tribes and only lately in the last blink
of an eyelash compared to this great
time scale have we begun coming together
again even knowing about each other so
gathering like this is kind of a
gathering of the tribes in which humans
from all over the world come together to
discuss common concerns but this is not
just any group of humans it's a group of
humans who have actually a possibility
to make things better I very much hope
that you are several people have asked
me why I as an astronomer am involved
with these issues and there are many
many different schemes of causality that
are responsible but I want to just
stress one I'm a planetary scientist
it's been my great good fortune to
participate in what is certainly never
before occurred in human history the
direct exploration of other worlds by
robots constructed by our species and so
for the last 25 years I've
been lucky enough to be involved with
the design and execution of missions to
other worlds in which a spacecraft flies
past or orbits or lands on another
planet or one of the moons of another
planet those other worlds are
extraordinarily beautiful highly
instructive as I'll mention later there
are very important lessons for our world
that we've gathered by studying other
worlds one of my interests has been the
search for life the possibility of
living things on those other worlds and
before we look no one is in a position
to know whether life exists on many
worlds in the solar system or on just
one only namely ours well we have now
recently completed the preliminary
reconnaissance of the solar system our
spacecraft have now passed beyond
Neptune and Pluto the outermost planets
we have gone past the worlds in the
solar system we have four spacecraft
heading out into the space between the
stars of those dozens of other worlds
that we have examined we have not found
any trace of life elsewhere in the case
of Mars for example where we landed two
spacecraft and examined the surface for
years we found not a mouse not a blade
of grass not a microbe not even an
organic molecule we have found the
stirrings and premonition
of life elsewhere organic molecules
being synthesized on worlds in the outer
solar system but no trace of life and
this gives a certain useful perspective
I think you can have dozens of worlds
that are complex rich environmentally
diverse and have life on only one of
them life is rare it is therefore
something precious and at the end of
this long set of voyages of exploration
I think it's very natural to turn our
site home again to recognize that what
we have here is precious and needs to be
cherished if you look at a picture of
the Earth from space or if you talk to
astronauts and cosmonauts who have been
in space one of the most striking
aspects of the view of the Earth from a
few hundred kilometers up is how thin
the atmosphere is there's just this
faint blue aura that surrounds the earth
it has a distinct appearance of
fragility and it is fragile the
thickness of the atmosphere compared to
the size of the earth is about the same
as the thickness of a coat of shellac on
a globe of the earth in a school say
there's not much air
or consider the ozone layer about which
we are rightfully concerned if that
entire layer were brought down into this
room the pressure and temperature of
this room it would be about the
thickness of this pinpoint that's all
the ozone there is to protect us from
the dangerous ultraviolet light of the
Sun when we humans started out our
numbers were very few our technological
powers were very limited
the idea that we could affect the global
environment was absurd and the issue of
course was never raised
but now our population is immense more
than five point one thousand million of
us our technological powers have become
vast even awesome and now we pose a
danger to this thin and fragile
atmosphere not intentionally not because
we intend to do it harm who would want
to harm the life-supporting environment
but simply because our technology is
powerful there are many of us and we are
still not very good at thinking ahead at
recognizing the future consequences of
present action I will come in a little
bit to to talk about at least one of
these environmental issues but you are a
group of parliamentarians you must make
decisions on policy you must figure out
how to decide which issues to devote how
much attention to and I'd like to talk a
little bit about that very grave and
important question
human history has faced this kind of
issue before and I want to describe to
you two cases that come from the classic
Western tradition of ancient Greece what
the policymakers do when faced with
predictions of catastrophe
the first story actually both of them
have to do the Greek god Apollo Apollo
was an Olympian god of the Sun but
beyond being in charge of sunlight
Apollo was also in charge of prophecy
that was one of his specialties all the
Olympian gods could see into the future
a little bit but Apollo did this on an
industrial scale
he established Oracle's all over the
class world the most famous of which was
at Delphi in Greece he sanctified the
priestess who is called the Pythia and
kings and aristocrats and occasionally
even ordinary people came to this Oracle
to beg to know what the future holds
among these supplicants was Croesus king
of lydia we remember him a little bit in
the phrase rich as Croesus part of the
reason he was so rich is that he was one
of the guys who invented money the first
coins were were minted in Lydia in his
time Lydia is in Anatolia contemporary
Turkey as happens to rich people on
occasion his ambitions could not be
contained within a small volume and so
according to the history of Herodotus he
got it into his head that it would be a
good idea to invade Persia Persia was
the superpower of the seventh century BC
the Persian king Cyrus had United the
Persians and the Metis into a very
powerful Empire so naturally Croesus had
a little reservation about going ahead
and invading Persia so naturally as
anyone would at that time
he sent a delegation of emissaries to
Delphi to ask questions and you can
imagine them Laden down with the opulent
gifts for the Delphi after to the Oracle
of Delphi because after all prophecy
doesn't come free and the question that
his emissaries put was what will happen
if Croesus makes war on Persia without
hesitation the Pythia instantly answered
he will destroy a mighty empire the gods
are with us Croesus must have thought
time to invade so he invaded and was
humiliatingly defeated not only was
Lydian power destroyed forever
but he himself was destined to live out
the rest of his days as a kind of minor
functionary in the Persian court
offering little pieces of advice too
often indifferent officials the kind of
hanger-on ex-king well time passed and
the injustice of it really got to him
after all he had played by the rules he
had gone and asked the Pythia he had
paid handsomely and she had done him
wrong so he sent another emissary this
one on a much more modest scale
appropriate to his diminished
circumstances and asked in effect how
could you do this to me
here's the answer as recorded in
Herodotus is history quote the prophecy
given by Apollo wren that if Croesus
made war on Persia he would destroy a
mighty empire now in the face of that
the priestess says if he had been well
advised he should have sent and inquired
again whether it was his own Empire or
that of Cyrus that was spoken of but
Croesus did not understand what was
nor did he question again and so he has
no one to blame but himself close quote
now if the Delphic Oracle is just a scam
to fleece credulous kings then of course
it would have needed excuses to explain
away the inevitable errors in prophecy
disguised ambiguities were its stocking
trade but the lesson of Croesus is
germane to the questions before us today
even of Oracle's we must ask questions
intelligent questions even when what
we're being told tallies with what we
want to hear the policymakers must not
blindly accept they must understand and
since the prophecies that concern us
today involve scientific issues the
policymakers must educate themselves on
science and this advice it seems to me
is fully applicable to the modern
Oracle's who are the scientists and the
think tanks and universities the policy
makers send sometimes reluctantly to ask
of these articles and the answer comes
back these days often the are khals
volunteer prophecies even when no one's
asked them the first thing to do is to
understand now I want to tell you
another story about Apollo and Oracle's
this one is quite different this is the
story of Cassandra princess of Troy it
begins just before the the Greeks under
Agamemnon invade Troy at the beginning
of the Trojan War Cassandra was the
smartest and the most beautiful of the
daughters of King Priam and Apollo
constantly on the prowl
all four attractive humans fell in love
with her strangely this almost never
happens in Greek myth she resisted his
advances
she said no so he tried to bribe her but
what could he give her she was already a
princess she was rich she was beautiful
she was happy but Apollo was very clever
he promised her the gift of prophecy and
that offer was irresistible she agreed
quid pro quo so Apollo did whatever it
is that gods do to make Sears and
Oracles and prophets out of mere mortals
but then scandalously Cassandra changed
her mind she said no again Apollo was
not amused
but he couldn't withdraw the gift of
prophecy because after all he was a God
and whatever else you might think of
them gods keep their promises so instead
he condemned her to a cruel and
ingenious fate but no one would ever
believe her prophecies whatever counting
here is in Aeschylus's play Agamemnon so
Cassandra predicts to her own people the
fall of Troy and nobody pays attention
she predicts the death of the leading
Greek invader Agamemnon and the Greeks
don't pay attention she even predicts
her own death and nobody was the
slightest bit interested they didn't
want to hear they made fun of her
both Greeks and Trojans called her the
Lady of many sorrows today maybe they
would dismiss her as a prophet of doom
and gloom
at the end of all this she says I
prophesied to my countrymen all their
disasters but they ignored her and they
were destroyed and soon stirred so is
she that's the other extreme in the
policy response to predictions of
disaster if we're faced with an ominous
prediction involving powerful forces
that may not be readily influenced or
even understood we have a natural
tendency to reject the advice to put it
off to ignore the prophecy dealing with
the danger might take time effort money
courage it's politically expensive it's
difficult it might require that we
change some priorities in our lives now
I don't for a moment want to suggest
that every prediction of disaster made
by scientists is true and there are many
cases in which scientists like everybody
else made mistakes but there's a way
there is a error-correcting mechanism
built into science part of the ethos of
science and that's why there's a
community that argues and checks each
other statements and yells and complains
that is a healthy and vigorous sign
nevertheless there's a tendency no
matter how well supported the prediction
of disaster is to be tempted to put it
aside what's more if the factor is
precipitating the the problem are
long-standing then the prediction itself
is a kind of rebuke why have we
permitted this peril to get so far
shouldn't we have informed ourselves
about it earlier don't we ourselves have
complicity in letting this come about is
now this is these are uncomfortable
ruminations that our own inattention or
inaction might have put us and our loved
ones in danger and so there's a natural
tendency to reject the whole business
it'll need better evidence we say
there's a temptation to minimize it to
dismiss it to forget it this is a very
common and very human response
psychiatrists have a name for it it's
called denial to deny the danger I don't
know if if the following remark is going
to translate at all it will pose a real
challenge to the translators but there's
a rock and roll group in America called
dire straits and there's a line in one
of their songs that goes denial ain't
just a river in Egypt
now these stories of Croesus and
cassandra represent the the two poles of
policy response to such predictions
Croesus himself representing the pole of
credulous uncritical acceptance
propelled in his case by greed and other
character Flores and the Greek control
in response to cassandra representing
the pole of stolid you know immobile
rejection of the possibility the job of
the policymaker is to steer a course
between these two souls and I believe
that it's perfectly possible to do that
and in the case of some of the problems
before us the seriousness of the issue
is so well-established that we cannot I
believe exercise denial anymore there
are a number of these global problems
depletion of the protective ozone layer
is certainly one but considering that we
are going to have a question period a
dialogue afterwards I'm not going to
take the time to discuss that here or
any of the other important issues that
you will be discussing at this meeting
save one and that one is greenhouse
warming in a way it's the most serious
it's the most difficult it responding to
it requires the greatest change in how
we think of the world and so let me try
and address that but before I do I just
want to point out that we now have a
precedent that the nations can get
together
and can agree on steps even expensive
steps to mitigate or avoid such a danger
and I'm referring to the Montreal
Protocol in which 33 I think nations
have agreed to phase out the production
of the ozone destroying molecule
chlorofluorocarbons CFCs despite the
fact that it will be expensive for the
industries involved and that is a
demonstration that the nations of the
world can work together on these issues
it's a sign of optimism a reason for
hope
now let me talk a little bit about the
greenhouse effect I myself got involved
in the greenhouse effect the son of the
giris said by studying it not on the
earth but on our nearest planetary
neighbor Venus where it is vastly larger
in proportions then it is here the
greenhouse effect is something like this
imagine the earth sitting in space and
the Sun let's imagine that that at that
bright television light is the Sun the
amount of sunlight falling on the earth
warms the earth the warm earth then
radiates back into space to cool itself
off and the temperature of the earth one
would think is determined by the balance
between the amount of sunlight that is
absorbed and the amount of radiation
that's radiated to space if you do that
calculation we know how bright the Sun
is we know how far away the earth is
from the Sun we know how much sunlight
is absorbed by the earth if you do that
calculation you would predict and it's
done in elementary astronomy and
meteorology courses you find that the
temperature of the earth would be 35
degrees centigrade cooler than in in
fact it is something's wrong with the
calculation what's wrong is that we've
forgotten something that the earth is
not airless that there is a thin layer
of atmosphere that surrounds the earth
some of that atmosphere is in front of
us right here in this room so I can see
people in the back of the room I hope
people in the back of the room can see
me our eyes work in visible light
ordinary visible light the air except in
places like Los Angeles and Mexico City
is transparent to ordinary visible light
on the other hand
in the infrared part of the spectrum
beyond the color red wavelengths longer
than red the atmosphere is not fully
transparent and at some wavelengths some
colors in the infrared it's opaque and
that means that if we have lots of
infrared absorbing gases in the
atmosphere they may not block the
sunlight that's coming in to warm the
earth but they will block the infrared
radiation that the earth radiates back
to space and then the atmosphere acts as
a kind of blanket warming the earth some
molecules in the air like oxygen and
nitrogen the most abundant ones don't
absorb almost not at all in the infrared
so they are not greenhouse gases but
other molecules like water vapor or
carbon dioxide or those CFCs I talked
about a moment ago do absorb in the
infrared and are greenhouse gases the
more of those gases the more infrared
absorption the more blanket and
everything else being equal the more the
temperature of the earth should rise
there is no question that since the
Industrial Revolution we have been
pouring co2 and other such gases carbon
dioxide co2 and other such gases into
the atmosphere recently because of the
exponential growth of our technology
we've been pouring many more of those
gases into the atmosphere including new
gases that were never known in nature
like CFCs and all the calculations show
that the temperature of the earth should
be increasing
we do not know precisely by how much
there is not yet perfect agreement
on these matters but the bulk of the
calculations show that temperature
increases of a few degrees centigrade in
the average temperature of the earth
should happen sometime in the next
century now that doesn't sound like very
much a few degrees centigrade it's a few
degrees centigrade warmer in this room
with the lights on them than with the
lights off what's a few degrees
centigrade but an average at the
temperature increase in the average
temperature of the earth of a few
degrees centigrade has much greater
implications for local and regional
temperatures and I'll show you an
example of that shortly some of these
predictions are very dire they include
the conversion of crop growing regions
into scrub desert including the American
Midwest these almost scrub desert they
involve the rising of sea level and the
eventual inundation flooding of coastal
cities all over the planet
they involve the destruction of natural
ecosystems the spread of disease the
obvious likelihood of conflicts over
water rights think of a place like
Bangladesh much of which is already
nearly at sea level and there is not the
fiscal resources to build dikes and
levees as has been done in Holland which
has a similar problem it seems very
clear that tens of millions of people
will find their homeland under water in
Bangladesh alone if some of these
predictions are fulfilled
there will be vast numbers of
environmental refugees
you can see that putting all of these
issues together we can foresee a very
serious set of problems that face all of
us there is essentially no winners
everybody all over the planet
is a loser now I would like to show a
few slides I think it's just ten and I
promised to go through them quickly this
is very dangerous for an after-dinner
speech and I recognize I'm taking a risk
but I want to illustrate a few of the
items that I've been saying and say them
in a in another way this picture is of
the surface of the planet Venus taken by
one of the Soviet Union's Venera series
of spacecraft first spacecraft to land
on the surface of Venus Venus is a it's
the nearest world it has the same mass
size density as the earth you might
figure it's very much like the earth but
it has a massive atmosphere ninety times
the pressure of the atmosphere of the
earth and that atmosphere is made
primarily of carbon dioxide co2 which we
know to be a major greenhouse gas the
temperature of this surface is I'm
trying to do a calculation in my head
it's about four hundred and seventy
degrees centigrade about 900 degrees
Fahrenheit it's hotter than the hottest
household oven it's hot enough to
melt tin or lead and this comes about
through a massive greenhouse effect so
if anyone tells you that there is a
doubt about whether a greenhouse effect
exists or can be serious please direct
them to the planet Venus
now I'm not proposing that what's
happened on Venus is that there were a a
race of Venusian who drove
fuel-inefficient autos and that's that's
how they got into this problem this
comes about as far as we know without
the intervention of supposedly
intelligent life but it is a very
important object lesson next slide
please
and speaking of planetary object lessons
I cannot resist the temptation to spend
just a moment with you on the planet
Mars this is a photograph taken by the
United States Viking one spacecraft in
1977 a lovely beautiful instructive
world that's the subject of another talk
I mentioned the antiseptic character of
this surface not a microbe not an
organic molecule why not the reason
seems to be that there is a planet-wide
ozone hole on Mars
there is essentially no ozone in the
atmosphere of Mars the ultraviolet light
strikes the surface of Mars unimpeded by
the Martian atmosphere and the result is
a surface which is made antiseptic by
oxidizing compounds peroxides super
oxides and this also may be a useful
reminder to us of the importance of an
ozone layer next slide now let me try to
just take you through a few slides
illustrating the greenhouse effect here
is this is a beautiful photograph taken
by the meteos at satellite of the
european space agency of africa and much
of europe taking an ordinary visible
light the next slide shows exactly the
same area photographed by exactly the
same satellite at almost exactly the
same moment but at a wavelength of 10
microns in the infrared this is a
wavelength where the atmosphere is still
mainly transparent in the infrared red
is hot and we can see the hot places on
the earth and by the way also you can
see over as a year and and much of
Central Africa a set of clouds which
also work in this case to keep the heat
in
but now next slide if we look at one of
the wavelengths where the atmosphere
absorbs we can make out none of the
features of the surface of the earth
we're looking here at high-altitude
features and the reason is that at this
particular way right the atmosphere of
the earth is opaque this is an
illustration of greenhouse how the
greenhouse works next slide
here is a picture notable in many
different respects one of which is that
it accompanied a very excellent op-ed
piece in The New York Times on Earth Day
by our Chairman senator Gore showing the
result of boring cores through the
Antarctic ice cap done by the Soviet
Vostok team in which are plotted both
the observed change in temperature over
the last tens of thousands of years and
the observed change in the amount of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere and
notice how well the two curves quite
different track each other
the temperatures are determined from
oxygen isotopes in this core the deeper
down in the core of the further back in
time and the carbon dioxide abundance in
the atmosphere is determined from little
bubbles of air that have been trapped in
the ice so each point in each depth in
the core corresponds to a certain moment
in the past history of your you
determine the temperature you determine
how much co2 is in the air when there's
more co2 the temperature is higher when
there's less co2 the temperature is
lower this is a very significant and
useful demonstration that adding
greenhouse gases to the air actually
does increase the temperature and now
the carbon dioxide abundance is much
higher than it's been anywhere in this
period and the imminent prediction is
that the temperatures will be much
higher as well and in fact even though
the average temperature of the earth has
not been much increasing during the
decade of the 1980s the decade of the
1980s still has
the five hottest years in the 20th
century and just speaking anecdotally
this year looks to be another hot here
next slide this is for three different
gases how much of the gas there is
against time in recent years this is the
carbon dioxide increase with time here
is a gas called methane its increase in
time here is one of the coral
fluorocarbons its increase in time
there's no question that human activity
and mainly the burning of fossil fuels
is increasing the amount of greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere next slide here
are this is one set of computer models
and I can't quite make out the times
just one
so I don't know if you can make this out
but there is a Mercator projection map
of the earth here Western Hemisphere
here eastern hemisphere here and it's
the same in each of these four maps
this is 1960 this is right now this is
2000 and this I can't quite make out but
it's about 2050 2020 2020 2050 thank you
and the browner it is the warmer it is
and you can see the clear trend and
something like this is the trend in all
of the three-dimensional general
circulation computer models that have
been run this one from the Goddard
Institute of Space Sciences in New York
and the next slide shows for just the
same circumstances there are maps
underneath here as well and for the same
years a measure of drought and you can
see the drought getting progressively
very serious now
what should we do about this
the next slide this is my last slide is
from a official White House hand out at
a meeting held just a week ago on global
warming and there were many issues
discussed in that handout one of which
was called balance balance and the
parlance of the White House by way I
understand this is a non partisan
gathering but on the other hand there is
glasnost now even in the Soviet Union so
I'm sure you will permit me a personal
remark balance in the view of the White
House you can clearly see it has two
pens on the scales of a balance on one
side is the planet Earth and on the
other side are six bars of gold and
maybe you can notice that the exactly
balance each other in the view of those
who put this picture together this is a
perfectly good way to address the
problem
I certainly happy to go along the White
House on this the question is is the
picture drawn correctly or might the
earth weigh more heavily than six bars
of gold I think it's perfectly possible
to treat the issue on the grounds that
the White House suggests but the answer
is not a perfect balance
between your and money because the earth
or at least the part of it that sustains
our life and civilization is priceless
and I would like to argue that before we
are absolutely sure which means that we
are either in desperate greenhouse
warming or not it would be wise to take
certain precautions re
steps may have the lights please and the
slides are
I'm not done now what should be done
what is a reasonable set of responses to
this new Oracle the set of mutually
supportive prophecies by the different
scientific Oracle's with some
differences between them of course the
main problem is the burning of fossil
fuels when you take a lump of coal and
burn it in the oxygen of the air the
carbon in the coal combines with the
oxygen in the air carbon sea oxygen o2
makes co2 it is a an irreducible
consequence of the burning of coal oil
natural gas petroleum wood and so on
one thing surely that can be done is to
have a more efficient burning of those
fossil fuels so for example in this
country the United States by the way is
the worst carbon dioxide producer on the
planet the Soviet Union is the second
worst and if we were to lump all the
countries in the developing world
together they would represent the third
worst producer of carbon dioxide and
therefore it is very important to
remember that this is an issue we are
all in together we are all in this
greenhouse together certainly the
countries that have the largest
responsibilities contribution should
have the largest responsibility but
everyone on the earth is producing this
stuff more efficient burning of fossil
fuels a third of almost 1/3 of US
production of carbon
so it's comes from driving cars and
buses trucks why do we drive cars that
get 20 miles per gallon when it is
perfectly feasible in an engineering
sense to have cars that get 60 miles a
gallon
everybody got 60 miles a gallon
everybody could go as far as they
ordinarily go and we would have reduced
the amount of co2 put up into the
atmosphere by internal combustion
engines by two-thirds and this goes
across the boards every area of energy
use can be made more efficient by
feasible technologies and by the way if
you think of the development of these
technologies it becomes very clear to
capitalists that there is money to be
made in dealing the environmental issues
it's not that the coal oil gas and auto
industries are going to go bankrupt
because they may have to change their
ways of doing things on the other hand
just the opposite this has a wide range
of investment opportunities for smart
corporations second thing we should do
is to make large-scale research and
development investments on alternatives
to fossil fuels the paradigm of these
alternatives is solar power which
converts sunlight into electricity or
sunlight into hot water producing no
polluting gases no greenhouse gases no
radioactive waste and such systems are
within hailing distance of being
competitive with other means of
generating electricity if we were to
include even in our minds a kind of tax
on the fossil fuel industry for the
damage that they do every time some co2
goes into the atmosphere solar
power would be fully competitive right
now with the burning of fossil fuels for
those regions of the country that that
have sunlight I happen to come from a
place in upstate New York which has
sunlight only rarely the third thing
that we ought to do is massive
reforestation on a global scale growing
trees take carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere they are a kind of anti
greenhouse machinery we plant a forest
co2 gets taken out of the atmosphere
there is a corporation not far from here
called I think Applied Energy Systems
it's in Arlington Virginia they are
building a power plant I think maybe
Coal Fired in Connecticut anyway
somewhere in the Northeast which will of
course put carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere
what a EES has committed to do is to
plant a forest in Guatemala which will
take out of the atmosphere the same
amount of carbon dioxide that its power
plant will put into the atmosphere over
the anticipated lifetime of that power
plant that's an example of responsible
corporate behavior instead of planting
forests we humans are destroying forests
at an amazing rate of an acre a second
an acre of land every second is denuded
of its trees worldwide this is stupid
and should stop and the final mitigating
step that I want to call your attention
to has to do with the population of the
human family all of these other issues
no matter how heroic we change our
practices in fossil fuel efficiency in
finding alternatives to fossil fuel in
planting forests they will all come to
naught if we don't do something about
the rapidly increasing population growth
on the planet every human has to burn
fuel to go about his or her daily lives
the more people the more greenhouse
gases now let me just say a couple of
words about that there is a very
mistaken view that you sometimes can
come upon in the developed world that
the problem with the population growth
in all those poor countries is that
those poor people don't understand why
they should limit their population or
that there is an unavailability of birth
control devices I believe the situation
is very different from that I believe
that the billion poorest people on the
planet tend to have many children out of
a careful cost-benefit analysis if
you're very poor it doesn't cost much to
raise two they might be helpful in
carrying the water and and the wood
since no one is educated you don't have
to pay at all for their education and if
a few of them survive they might be able
to take care of you in your old age
because your country doesn't provide
anything like Social Security it makes
sense on the timescale of a human
lifetime under such circumstances to
have many children and it is clear we
just look back in the developed world a
few generations the generation of my
grandparents and great-grandparents for
example people had huge families they do
not have them today why not all over the
world there is a very interesting
phenomenon that's been called the
demographic transition and it occurs
east and west Buddhist countries and
Catholic countries communist countries
and capitalist countries and it goes
like this
when the per capita income is raised
above a certain very low level by
American standards the population growth
rate automatically turns down people
make that cost-benefit analysis anew and
decide to have fewer children the
solution the principal solution to the
world population crisis is to raise the
standard of living of the poorest people
on the planet and so if we wish
consistently to follow through the
implications of our proper concern about
global warming we must address the issue
of poverty and I believe in the old
adage of providing not fish but fish
hooks
there are ways for the developed
countries to provide self-sufficiency to
help provide self-sufficiency for the
poorest people on the planet and the
cost
can be readily estimated and the key
fact is that it is enormous ly less than
the amount of money that we spend on
arms every year the world military
budgets are now at one trillion dollars
1 million million dollars every year a
modest fraction of that would be enough
to raise the standard of living of the
billion poorest people on the planet and
there's one other aspect of that man has
to do with the status of women there are
a few places on the planet which have
substantial per-capita income and still
have very large population growths and
they are all places I believe where the
status of women is very low where women
are not educated are not permitted to be
educated and are not co-equal with males
so I think a very sober none ideological
approach to these issues we drive anyone
concerned with these global
environmental issues - the reduction of
poverty and the increase of the status
of women worldwide you don't have to
have any sense it seems to me of the
Justice or humanitarian aspects of these
mitigating steps although they're
obviously there you only have to be
concerned about the future of the planet
and you're driven in that direction
Yevgeniy if Tishchenko in his stirring
poem talked about moral autumn it seems
to me that if we merely have a sober
assessment of the situation facing us we
could automatically find ourselves in a
moral spring
there is one final aspect of this issue
I'd like to mention and that is
molecules don't have passports molecules
are very stupid but they do not
understand the importance of the concept
of national sovereignty they do not
recognize national boundaries and on
those pictures of the Earth from space
it's very hard to make out the national
boundaries the national boundaries are
man-made the earth is really there so
carbon dioxide or CFCs put up by one
nation do not stay over that nation they
are carried by the general circulation
of the Earth's atmosphere all over the
planet and therefore we are all in this
together these global environmental
issues have a fascinating trends
ideological trans national and trans
generational character they force us to
think of the planet as a unity they
force us to think about our
responsibility to future generations
there is a passage in the Bible in the
book of Proverbs which sometimes haunts
me it goes they set an ambush for their
own lives if we do nothing on these
global environmental issues that's what
we will be doing but if we use our
intelligence which
is the secret of the success of our
species if we use our ability to foresee
the future consequences of present
actions if we draw upon our common
humanitarian feelings then I think that
we are fully capable of solving these
problems and in the process making the
world a far better place than it is now
I wish you all success in your work
we have time for only three questions if
you do not speak in English
please do not hesitate to ask your
question anyway we have headsets up here
as well so anyone who would like to ask
a question please raise your hand and
stand and we will repeat the question
for those who might not hear it three
questions who would like to ask the
first
the CFS have a large effect on the
zoning
not more carbons destroyed that was
already
also knowing that 80% within deities are
reduced the more in the form of a.m.
in spite of this Sonia is right status
and mode thousand - question the
questioner who some of the gore tells me
is from Egypt asks the perfectly
reasonable question the CFCs are mainly
made in the northern hemisphere and the
biggest destruction of the ozone layer
is a whole over the continent of
Antarctica as far south as you can go
how does this come about the answer has
to do with the circulation of the
Earth's atmosphere the movement of air
at high altitude the CFCs are are
remarkable they were invented by
brilliant chemists who were motivated to
find a perfectly harmless and inert
molecule to use as the working fluid in
refrigerators and air conditioners
another other useful functions they made
a molecule so inert that it's impossible
to destroy it down here so the molecule
leaks out of an air conditioner and it
bounces off molecules in the air it
bounces off telephone poles and
buildings does no damage to it at all
eventually they are carried to
stratospheric altitude and it's there
that they meet ozone molecules they are
match and destroy them but that
circulation carries the CFC molecules
all over the planet including to the
South Pole and there there is a vortex
of polar air and a kind of cloud that is
prevalent there and it's that mix which
makes the greatest destruction of ozone
happening over the South Pole however
there is evidence of the ozone layer
thinning at many other light
and Senator Gore reminds me that there
is one not quite as as thin yet over the
North Pole
other questions
here is a question rather similar to the
to the previous one why did carbon
dioxide increase 10,000 years ago surely
there were no fuel inefficient
automobiles then the carbon dioxide
content of the Earth's atmosphere has
been oscillating varying within certain
limits over as far back into Earth
history as we're able to determine the
important point and and the reasons
obviously do not involve human beings or
human technology or probably not ten
thousand years ago was a special time
for humans in which we our numbers were
growing very much was the end of the
last ice age maybe we had some
contribution there but before that
surely not there are a set of natural
processes which increase or decrease the
amount of carbon dioxide in the air the
more growing trees for example the more
carbon dioxide the less carbon dioxide
in the air and forests and plants are
destroyed and grow for all sorts of
reasons including the motion of
continents and the impact of objects
from space but the main point is that
the variation of the carbon dioxide has
been within limits and is now rising out
of that range that it has in the past
and that rise out of the range is
without a doubt due to human activity
senator Gore do we have time for another
question or two or is as the hour one
more question
I'll be glad to repeat the question
but
remaining tropical forests we already
have but our class diminishing and it so
happens that by coincidence the only
remaining tropical forests on earth
happened to be in that region countries
who sent around central air Western
Amazonia and Southeast Asia including
the Philippines and our country for
example have 15 million dwellers of the
upland areas putting pressure on the
forest because there is not an eternity
of livelihood and in 46 percent of our
GNP goes to death surveys there is no
way we can help these people and the
flower for isn't going fast
it's it'll be gone by the new 2000 and
I'm not sure if the situation is the
same in other countries
now since the creditor countries bio
incidents as well happen to be the co2
and we will live in one ecosystem can we
not have some kind of a burden Siri we
would be able to conserve our foreign
number one number two companies also
because of their preoccupation on the
bottom line do sorts of all sorts of
stupid things our preoccupation of June
without consideration of the cost of
environmental degradation or destruction
also we have to force ourselves to the
same panelists and our countries in
Europe that are now in the VMP
population the cost of environmental
degradation and destruction is there a
way these can be the worldwide global
scale also be a development in the
future thank you thank you I clearly
made a mistake by not asking you to to
come up here that was a very eloquent
statement thank you so much well the the
question had several parts to it one was
the distinction between growing forests
and conserving forests and surely
existing forests should be conserved not
so much because they take carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere but because they
are a unique repository of species
diversity we are destroying plants and
animals and I mean individual animals we
are making species of plants and animals
extinct so that they will never live
again on earth at an appalling rate I
don't think we have a right to do that
in the first place and in the second
place there are many practical uses that
such plants and animals can have for the
human species
so it's foolish as you correctly said to
do that secondly the question has said
in places like the Philippines where he
comes from the forests remaining stands
of forests old forests are being
destroyed because poor people need the
trees for lumber for firewood and so on
and this is connected with the large
fraction of the gross national product
of such nations that goes to the
retirement of debt the questioner asks
if international debt the questioner
asks if we're all in this greenhouse
together and if the developing countries
the one
that have lent the money are the biggest
polluters on the planet might there not
be a reason for them to ease that
retirement requirements or you can say
this but maybe you meant
cancel them altogether you want my
personal opinion absolutely the the idea
of a crushing debt burden prevents
education prevents development it
prevents the demographic transition
which is needed to control population
growth and this then brings me to the
last point which has to do the
distinction between short term and long
term goals if we always focus on the
short term we will lose we have to
simultaneously worry about short term
and long term issues now for politicians
is a particular concern here there is a
temptation to take steps which will have
benefits during the term of office of
the politician in the United States this
is two years for representatives for
years for presidents and six years for
senators but the issues we're talking
about are 10 30 50 years in the future
if politicians are only concerned about
the shortest term turnaround so that the
benefits of their policies can be reaped
while they are still in office then the
need to make long-term planning is going
to to be missed but there's one way in
which long term and short term
objectives can be joined and that is if
politicians who are solely devoted to
the short term are voted out of office
then
eventually there will only be
politicians who worry about the long
term so you know what you have to do and
those of us who are not politicians know
what we have to do thank you Carl Sagan
has said that he will remain here in
this room visiting with those who did
not have a chance to ask a question and
will be glad to talk with you
individually about the questions after
we conclude our formal session here this
evening let me make two points before we
call it a night first of all anyone who
wishes to speak during this
interparliamentary conference will have
an opportunity to speak we want to hear
from all the voices that are represented
around the world here in this room
please let us know when you would like
to speak during the discussion of the
working group reports or during the
debate on Wednesday morning on the
conference resolutions and we will make
certain that you will have an
opportunity to speak we heard in the
last question an important message that
those of us from the developed world
must hear during this conference Carl
Sagan said during his address the issue
of the global environment is linked to
the issue of poverty interdependence is
one of the themes we will be discussing
the second point in closing is we want
to begin our sessions this week promptly
at the hour indicated
in the program tomorrow morning for
example 8:30 a.m. means 8:30 a.m. please
be on time because we will begin at 8:30
a.m. thank you all very much and join me
in thanking Carl Sagan again for a
wonderful speech Thank You Carl